vehicle is pulling a u-turn
um no construction he's just doing
donuts in there the intersection of
Eddie Road in Sinclair a suspect is
caught on camera blatantly taunting
police doing donuts and enticing
officers to chase him but all that fun
comes to a crashing halt when he tries
to make a break for it but crashes into
a parked squad car
[Music]
the entire incident plus the suspect's
arrest all caught on dash and body
camera video
that sucks
should have went to the bathroom before
you can escapade
all this happened on September 11th in
Bratton all Ohio just outside of
Cleveland just before three o'clock that
morning officers noticed a black BMW
driving strangely deliberately slowing
down Nero squad car but then speeding
off when the sirens were turned on
oh shit
last year ago again
[Music]
dash camera video shows the suspect
later identified as 20 year old Joseph
Littlejohn doing donuts making multiple
u-turns and even dancing in his vehicle
as officers watch on officials later
determined the BMW he was driving had
been stolen
go ahead
are not able to do something about this
dispatch he's doing donuts and talking
us
96 he's right in front of us sitting at
Eddie and Saint Claire
negative
[Music]
vehicle setting was found on Eddie we're
turning around
at first officers chase after Littlejohn
[Music]
but as he continues taunting them
officials stop the chase
people is pulling a u-turn
um
he's just doing donuts in there the
intersection of Eddie Road in Sinclair
I'm not pursuing him even though he
wants me to
him
I'm not able to do something about this
this guy's just doing donuts
officers can then be heard describing
the erratic driving as little John again
speeds by people just pass me on the
opposite lane
to me
at one point the suspect even opens the
driver's side door and begins Driving
With It Wide Open
vehicle is now sitting on the Hill Road
Bridge there with the driver side door
open
and the nail is
letting the car roll at the
same
amidst all this little John continues
his unsafe driving even traveling on the
wrong side of the road that's him
probably walking back around yeah
same thing
he's going oh he almost went the wrong
way on the highway
yep
Vehicles just weren't head on I mean
vehicle keeps going from the bridge to
actually
up and down
but it all goes off the rails when in an
effort to escape from police Little John
drives backwards down the road and
crashes into a squad car in a pole after
that another Squad crashes into the BMW
[Music]
yeah
foreign
body camera video shows these same
moments from another perspective
after the crash Little John hops out of
the stolen vehicle and runs off dash
camera video shows officers chase after
him
this video shows the moments from the
crash all the way to the chase when
little John is tackled to the ground
you all right
come here buddy come here talking come
here yes
Market clear pocket cash pocket
pocket cash pocket
body camera video from another officer
shows these same moments from another
angle
what's in the other one
Little John is tased multiple times but
still refuses to cooperate with police
Let It Go
oh yeah pull your hair down go
I know
I'll talk to him
it's a gun I know it is
you want to get fucking shot over this
Let It Go
let go of it
let's shoot me first
excuse me
excuse me you're gonna get bit you're
gonna get bit you're gonna get tased
until you put that arm out oh no
do I get bit
thank you
okay
let me go okay all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but when things calm down little John
asks officers to pull down his mask but
they refuse
shut up now
all right
just get your breath you're good
you're ready what
okay what do you want
I'm not pulling your mask down please I
don't care about your mask
oh yeah okay that's great you're talking
and breathing perfectly fine right now
are you ready yeah we're gonna stand you
up stand up
if you try to fight me I'm gonna put you
in the ground again you understand me
stand off
get up get up
eventually Little John cooperates and
officers detain him ready to roll
out of here
good boy
after he's in cuffs Little John
continues to complain about problems
breathing but officers push back
what's up
please
why
I can't either
and I'm good
we're having those complaints when
you're riding around
they'll be here in a minute okay
put two put one I want one set of cuffs
on him
you try to move so I'm gonna drop a knee
on you do you understand me yeah it's
not gonna be pretty I'm gonna drop all
my weight on you you're not gonna like
it okay
oh he's already looking
swoop them under and it ain't happening
okay stop moving your hands
okay breathe oh
if you're talking you're breathing
I think Reef
I can't breathe
you're talking still so you know how I
know you're breathing but you're still
talking you feel myself
oh that sucks
should have went to the bathroom before
your little escapade
Little John maintains he needs to go to
the hospital so EMS is called to the
scene
just so you know this isn't getting you
out of jail we're gonna go with you to
the hospital and then we're gonna take
you to jail so
he ain't gonna fly with me you're still
going all right just so you know okay if
you take care of yourself all right as
he's being loaded into the ambulance
Little John pulls his shirt over his
face but officers pull it right off yeah
oh hey don't do that you said you can't
breathe remember you don't want to put
your shirt over your face
can you stop moving
yeah that's gonna help that's not gonna
help your breathe in there oh wait you
don't want to be on the news that's not
going to help
you can't breathe I don't want your
shirt over your face you might suffocate
yourself you don't want to do that just
looking out for yourself
after Little John was taken into custody
officials recovered a gun in that stolen
BMW he was arrested and now faces
multiple charges including fleeing and
eluding an officer and having a weapon
Under Disability reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie